and she is the eldest daughter of the
wealthiest house in the realm
she comes from unimpeachable valyrian
stock
and she has targaryen blood
wants to mislike
she is 12.
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about house of the dragon's second
episode where we get to know the
motivations of the individual players in
this game a little better if unlike me
you haven't read the book to know where
things are going then i guess there was
a fairly big development at the end
overall palace intrigue with a side of
complicated family dynamics is what's on
the menu i think they did a commendable
job of serving that up for the second
week in a row while fleshing out some of
these situations in a way the book never
took the time to i'll be getting into
all of what happened and what i thought
about it and if for some reason you're
here without having seen the rogue
prince yet then be warned that this will
contain spoilers i will be discussing
the book and the original series but i
won't be giving away any future spoilers
about what will happen and with that out
of the way let's get into it
one of the most memorable parts about
watching game of thrones was the opening
credits and theme and now we have one
for house of the dragon this wasn't
included in my advanced copy so i
haven't had a chance to really break it
down but i did get a sort of pavlovian
response to the theme when it kicked in
and i like the idea that we're seeing
this recreation of old valyria with the
blood and everything else that's going
on there so i'll probably talk about
this more next week we opened the
episode proper with a shot of pirates
being slowly picked apart by crabs
nothing about this looks good corliss
alluded to it in the first episode they
call this meerish guy craggis drajar the
crab feeder due to his invented method
of punishing his enemies here you see
that he has them tied to stakes on the
ground at low tide where they wait for
it to come in and die by drowning and in
the meantime there's the crabs at the
small council they're discussing the
death of the lord commander of the
kingsguard sir ryam redwine he appeared
in the first episode and i suppose he
took ill in the six months that had
passed since then he'll be replaced by
harold westerling and he wants to get
busy right away to add a replacement to
get the king's guard back up to their
full compliment of seven members corliss
busts in and says that he wants to
retake the stepstones from the crab
feeder becerras is reluctant to act
because he's not prepared to start a war
with the free cities in case you've
forgotten these are in essos they're
called the free cities because all of
them except braavos were founded for
different reasons by valyria but they
were allowed to rule themselves braavos
was the exception in that it was started
by some escaped slaves several
characters visited them in the original
series daenerys started her journey
hiding out at illyrio mopatis's place in
pentos in season one and varys took
tyrion there in season five after he
killed his father arya went to the house
of black and white in braavos to find
the faceless men and that's also where
the iron bank is from you remember
they're the people that the crown goes
to when it needs an infusion of cash
there are nine free cities in total and
in the book the triarchy is made up of
lis tyrosh and mir here when vasirus is
pushed he says he has acted by sending
enboys to pentos and volantis so i'm not
sure if they switch them up or if this
is to imply he sent them somewhere
neutral to have their talks the stepsons
are a group of small islands that legend
says were created when the children of
the forest used their magic to destroy a
land bridge called the arm of dorne that
connected westeros to essos this was
during their war with the first men who
were using it as their way to relocate
to westeros this was about 12 000 years
before aegon's conquest and of course it
didn't work to stop the immigration
the islands themselves aren't important
but the trade route connecting the
narrow and summer seas is and that's why
corliss wants to act when the king isn't
interested we see corliss get a little
personal we learned that damon went to
dragonstone rather than going back to
his wife as he was ordered to and he's
been posted up there for six months
without any protest from his brother as
she's performing her role as cup bearer
rhaenyra interjects that they have
dragon riders and her father should send
them to take care of it her idea is to
make a show of force and the whole room
silently agrees that she's talking out
of turn otto suggests they find a better
use of the princess's talents which is
another way of saying that they don't
want her involved in matters of the
state they send her to look at the
kingsguard candidates instead she sees a
member of house karen which is from the
stormlands loyal to house baratheon and
a malister from seaguard in the
riverlands but she's concerned because
they just seem like a bunch of turning
knights in other words none of them have
seen actual combat other than sir
kristin cole his introduction as the son
of a steward of the lord of black haven
indicates he's basically a nobody
compared to these other guys and i kind
of loved how he's standing alone with no
banner or squire right there between
what i think are knights from house
craig hall and tarly in episode 1 we saw
him best damon so we know he's a skilled
fighter and while renera says she's
choosing him because of his experience
this is also going to be her personal
protector so it seems like there might
be more to it especially in the way she
looks at him compared to the others otto
tries to talk to her about the politics
of things saying that seaguard for
instance provides protection from
reavers from the iron islands this is
part of his job and he's not wrong but
she's insistent saying her father should
be protected by someone with combat
experience and she ends up getting her
way you get the sense that he has to let
her do what she wants but he doesn't
much like it and there's a lot to
consider in these first few scenes
rhaenyra has been the named heir for six
months but you don't get the sense that
people are enthusiastic about the
situation a little later we'll see her
at the sept with alison and that she
just wants her father to see her as more
than his little girl also when otto is
trying to talk to her out of picking
kristen we see rhaenys looking on from a
distance and we'll see more of her in a
bit in his chambers viserys talks about
valyrian history with allison as they
look at this huge model of the freehold
he has and it turns out that he actually
didn't build it i imagine dads
everywhere who like to go out to their
shops to work on their projects let out
a collective sigh sorry but this king
might not be just like you after all it
turns out he just looks over the text
and plans things out and then has his
stone masons do all the real work for
him but hey he's still a sucker for
history and he tells her about the
height of the freehold when they had
over a thousand dragons and a navy large
enough to span the seas of the world he
drops a miniature dragon as he's telling
her that the glory of old valyria will
never be seen again and that provides a
moment for them to touch hands and gaze
into each other's eyes it will also be a
way for her to further endear herself to
him when she has it repaired later he
changes the subject to rhaenyra saying
he wishes they could talk and then asked
alison not to mention that they have
these conversations he does get a chance
to talk to his daughter over dinner a
little later it's fairly awkward and
while he gets to express the love he had
for her mother it ends with neither one
of them being very satisfied and one of
the funniest things the show has done is
have him sitting way more comfortably
with his hand and a bowl full of maggots
in the very next scene he's way more
relaxed in that situation this is an
effort to fix his hand which he cut on
the iron throne and as i mentioned in my
last video that's a lore thing that's
supposed to be an indication that the
king isn't fit to rule the kingdom
he tells otto about corliss and rainey's
visit and their proposal for him to
marry their 12 year old daughter on
paper this makes sense as corliss
pointed out it would bring the two
houses of old valeria together they have
dragons and he has a powerful navy and
it would make for a powerful bond and
show the kingdom that there are better
days ahead with grand maester melos
being there that means that there's two
members of the small council present and
it's one floor and one against because
otto really wants him to marry his
daughter he can't actually come out and
say that it would look like he was
overreaching his station but it's not
like he's going to get behind the idea
of him marrying laina and the second
funniest thing the show does is have him
walk with this would-be 12-year-old
bride as the kid she is she just wants
to talk about dragons which is super
cute and he tries to at least answer her
questions saying that he was belarian's
last writer you know that he claimed him
right before he died viserys wasn't much
of a dragon rider because he never
claimed another one after that she
brings up vegar and we find out that
this other old and giant dragon is out
there on its own somewhere because it's
too large for the dragon pit it's one of
those things where you know this type of
thing happened throughout history for
reasons related to power and they do a
fine enough job of laying out why it
would make sense but then you think
about what would this actually be like
and they show that it's just as absurd
as you think it would be when an adult
and the child he's about to marry try to
have a conversation rhaenys and renera
talk and the queen who never was lays
out the reality of the situation even if
it's not to her daughter the king will
remarry and he will produce more heirs
and if one of them is a male then at
least some people will expect him to be
the next king rhaenyra points out that a
lot of lords bent the knee to her and
swore fealty but she's speaking from the
experience of being passed over and says
that the men of the kingdom would rather
put the realm to the torch than let a
woman ascend to the iron throne in some
ways their two situations are quite
different but seeing how the people
closest to the king aren't exactly
jumping in line behind renera does make
it seem like that she's probably not
wrong speaking of being passed over
after not getting his brother's
attention by sitting in dragonstone for
half a year damon decides to steal a
dragon's egg to further stir things up
he says that mazaria is with child that
he'll be making her his second wife like
their ancestors used to do and he
invites his brother to attend the
wedding becerras sees this for what it
is and is almost set to ignore him again
until renera finds out that he took the
same egg she chose to put in bail on the
air for a day's cradle before her mother
died when he hears that he's ready to go
get it back himself but otto steps in
partly because it's his job to keep the
king safe but also because he hates
damon and wants to make it seem like his
brother doesn't care enough about him to
actually go it all makes for a nice shot
of dragonstone where things get pretty
tense everyone present knows this is
going to turn into a bloodbath
especially when caraxes makes an
appearance but it's still a little hard
to see how damon can back down the whole
thing is a farce to get his brother's
attention and it's not working and it
really could have gone sideways if
rhaenyra didn't show up and talk sense
into him i suppose it's obvious but i
still have to mention that this is what
happens when people in these positions
don't get what they want they throw
their little tantrums and other people
end up getting hurt and i thought they
did a pretty good job of showing
mazaria's point of view in this in that
she doesn't appreciate being used as a
prop he thinks that he would be able to
protect her and tries to tell her not to
worry but from her perspective and she's
definitely not wrong she is expendable
and this doesn't do anything but paint a
target on her back she says you are
targaryen you can afford to play your
stupid games with the king which of
course we see that playing out in front
of us in real time she points out that
she isn't there because she wants his
gold or power for herself she came to
him to be liberated from the fear that
she's known for as long as she can
remember this is something that damon
would never consider because the
characters at the center of this story
believe their owed respect and deference
and to get what they want based on who
they are they were born into this and
have had that reinforced throughout
their lives having been raised at the
center of an empire at its height they
like to talk a lot about the duty that
goes along with that but generally still
behave like privileged spoiled brats
because they can generally speaking when
things go wrong because of the decisions
they make they won't experience the
worst of it and so it makes sense here
to show the perspective of someone else
who would back in king's landing
becerras isn't coming around to the idea
of marrying laina and he goes to his
master of laws lionel strong for an
unencumbered opinion he re-tells him all
the reasons why it makes sense in a very
straightforward way with the added she
will mature when faced with the obvious
problem of her being 12. in no uncertain
terms he says you should wed lana
valerian mike grace he should give
corliss what he wants and fix him at his
side permanently before he can respond
he's surprised when he gets word that
the princess has returned from
dragonstone he goes to ream her out
because she's his only heir and she went
behind his back put herself in danger
and if something were to happen then
that would put the future of their house
in question she points out that she did
it to retrieve the egg without bloodshed
she's probably not wrong about not
knowing nevada would have been able to
do that as much as the king is bothered
by what damon's doing he's still his
brother she knows they care about each
other and then he comes around when he
realizes she's a lot like her mother
they share a moment where he again tells
her how hard losing emma has been and
when she tells him that it pleases her
to know that she's not alone in that he
transitions to saying that the small
council is pressuring him to marry it's
a return to the uncomfortable where they
talk about each other in this detached
way as if they're not right there
sitting in front of each other the
actors do a great job of navigating away
from a loving father talking to his
daughter to a king who is bound by duty
in her response renera matches that and
gives him a way out he has to do this
because it's his responsibility as the
king his first duty is to the realm and
she adds that her mother would have
understood just as she does because
these are two people who are not capable
of talking in a completely honest way in
this circumstance you have to look past
the actual words they're saying her
father is telling her that he'll never
replace her mother just like he'd never
replace her as heir but also saying that
they need to do everything they can to
protect their family's position this is
him confirming the first part of what
rhaenys told her earlier she plays the
role she's been given to be supportive
in a selfless way but it's also not
clear if she's pulling it off she didn't
ask to be named air but now that she has
been you can see through her reaction
that she doesn't like the idea of it
being taken away from her he's also
completely talking around what his real
issue with taking a queen is and so when
the small council meets a little later
she's just as caught off guard as
corliss valerian is when he announces
that he's going to marry alison it's a
moment where reality shatters your ideas
about who you are and what you're
capable of ronira had been supportive
she understood the situation and she was
willing to go along with it for her
family faced with the idea of her father
marrying her close friend and being
completely blindsided by it hurts her in
a way that makes her leave the room
corliss reacts exactly as lionel said he
would and leaves himself but unlike
renera we get a chance to see where he
goes with it he invites damon over to
his island to meet with him because as
he presents it they're both men who've
had to cut their way through the world
and you can see where he's coming from
at this point in history his family is
richer than the lannisters or the
hightowers what he's saying about his
personal history is true he built that
up in a way that the likes of the
current targaryens can't understand and
i don't want to go into that completely
right here but he set out on nine great
voyages and made a name for himself
while amassing a fortune his house goes
back to old deliria they might even be
older than the targaryens and i love how
he adds according to some text there but
there's still a big difference since his
family weren't dragon lords by marrying
rhaenys he brought dragons into his
house but forming an alliance with damon
here would allow him to do what he wants
without too much worry about how viserys
might respond they've drilled his
reluctance to move against his brother
into our heads and corliss picked up on
that and it's something he can use to
his advantage plus what he's saying to
win him over here is basically sincere
he knows damon doesn't really have a
place he's got that second sun energy
and now he's outside of the line of
succession the realms fighters are also
itching for action and as the episode
comes to an end you get the sense that
these two might be able to make that
happen as a person who is a big fan of
the world george rr martin created i
can't help but enjoy the chance to dig
back into all of this stuff that part of
me is really enjoying how they're adding
to the story and leaning into presenting
these characters with chances to do
something different there is an
inevitability baked in because most
people know the realm isn't this way
during game of thrones so they are
making the effort to try to make us care
about what happens to these characters i
thought it worked best this week with
alison who spent most of her time pushed
off to the side of everything else that
was going on i liked how they show her
always putting on her best face and
saying the right things while showing
her nervously picking at her fingernails
when she's alone the fact that her
father brings this up in the way he does
and just how clueless that makes him
seem about what she's going through what
he's encouraging her to put herself
through does a lot to add to that
character in the book all of this just
sort of happens off page and that makes
her less sympathetic i think here we see
someone who is doing what she thinks she
has to based on her position and the
world she lives in if you think about it
she gave both father and daughter sound
advice when they confided in her i also
liked that there were some genuinely
funny parts mixed in there viserys just
casually dipping his hand into those
maggots and effortlessly conversing with
otto after seeing him struggle to talk
with his daughter was great little laina
being so pumped up to talk about dragons
in the middle of that absurdity and i
didn't mention it before but damon
tossing the egg back to renera before he
backed down on the bridge was weirdly
endearing there was a lot of interesting
connections to the original series and i
think my favorite was seeing the sep
that's in king's landing at this time
you'll notice that it's not that sept
the great septa bailor that cersei did
her thing to in the season six finale
that was constructed by and named after
king balor the blessed whose reign
doesn't happen until decades after what
we're watching now having said all of
that i think the side of me that's a fan
of great tv is a little less convinced
this week there were a couple of things
that felt sort of clunky in this episode
and i'll just mention too the sequence
when renera is going to his chambers
after being called to meet with her
father it all felt a little bit off the
score kicks in and it seems like they
wanted to have this build up that didn't
really land there's also this long shot
where you can almost mistake millie
alcock for emilia clarke which i don't
think does either character very many
favors also the long slow reveal that
corliss is talking to damon felt
unnecessary they're just small cracks
but they're the kinds of things that
could add up generally speaking my
enjoyment of the lore allows me to gloss
over these types of things but i hope
this is more about the fact that this is
the first season rather than signs of
not being able to live up to the hype
they have the advantage of mostly
keeping things close to king's landing
with regular trips to dragonstone and
the nerd in me can't wait to see more of
the house valerian seat at driftmark you
do get a nice little tease of some of
the treasures he's collected on his
voyages but this is also a big
undertaking even scaled down westeros is
daunting so i hope they'll be able to
make it all work i would say so far they
are especially in moments like the shot
of the bridge at dragonstone this looked
amazing and they did a good job of
presenting the different sides and what
the motivations were in a way that is
very game of thrones the acting is also
strong there are a ton of great small
moments delivered by everyone and it's
all very promising for what's to come
i'm excited to see what happens next and
i think that's a great place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about the episode how do you
feel about damon becoming the rogue
prince and i'm especially interested to
see how things landed for people who
don't know what's coming please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon